[Applause]
defiant protesters again marched through
the streets of mandalay on sunday
in strong voice and in large numbers
they were clearly unbowed by the
violence of the day before
that's when the security services shot
dead at least six people in a crackdown
in myanmar's second city and injured
many more
but with the death toll rising a call
for revolution
from the former vice president now
leading a civilian administration
in hiding this is the darkest moment of
the nation
and the moment when the dawn is close
this is the time for our citizens to
test their resistance against the dark
moments
speaking of a new federal democracy the
message was clearly aimed at bringing
diverse
ethnic armed groups together to overcome
the army
and their coup
when forming our resistance unity plays
a vital role
despite our differences in the past this
is the time we must grip our hands
together
to end the dictatorship for good
these diverse ethnic armed groups are
scattered across myanmar's borderlands
divided they don't represent a
significant threat to the military
who've been fighting them for decades
united
they could be a considerable obstacle
but there's long been distrust between
these groups and the nld
or national league for democracy
bringing them together
would be no small task
in peaceful defiance protesters break
the curfew to honor the dead
in candlelit vigils across the country
we come out on the street to show that
we are against military dictatorship
by breaking the curfew order imposed by
the junta
we will continue fighting but as the
military continues with its brutal
tactics on the streets calls for a
revolution
that's not so peaceful may gain
increasing support
tony chang al jazeera